whoa hold on there gladiator we may have
a challenger for the title of most
yellow movie ever made
ah the days when Martin Lawrence got Top
Billing over Will Smith now what is this
having a picnic in my car the real
question is how long is Marcus had this
obviously fast-food burger and Mike's
car did he buy it and save it for later
it might go through the drive-through
and hand Marcus a burger without
explaining his car rules I'm mad that's
what married means it means you sleep
together which you can get now movie
presents this as a hilarious unique
observation instead of a lazy rewrite of
a joke Milton Berle probably told you
won't get that far there was
considerably more than one fry to pick
up they make Mike seemed like a really
anal person by making the fries singular
but it was half a bag of fries that fell
into the seat gee I wonder where this
movie to explore oh thanks on the decoy
yes my plan is to kill this guy in a cop
uniform call it in and the entire police
station goes to investigate it luckily
for the professional thieves that is
exactly what happens goes gonna kill me
luckily for the professional teams
goddamn taco is gonna kill it
luckily for the professional thieves
goddamn taco makes security guy fall
asleep at the exact moment the monitors
mess up
six minutes they then proceeded to do
all this in six minutes
first off orgy of evidence that there
are kids in the house and they take
theirs into the parents bedroom and
that's where it stays for some reason
second off in this shot the toys are all
on Marcus's side of the bed and there's
nothing but sensible mom things on her
side but when the kids run and the signs
have completely switched got that right
detective this one to second line is
what marg Helgenberger submitted for her
CSI audition well well yeah last night
man listen why don't y'all just how your
cousin's bring the back and I'll get
some sleep
that's definitely racist your mama
snorted up over Oh that is also racist
it's almost like this movie thinks
racism is funny so long as all the
characters on screen laugh along with it
so they kill a decoy it empties the
station very smart smart for them I
guess really stupid for the police
station full of cops but they don't kill
a real cop because they know they had a
whole force on theirs
I honestly don't understand how the
entire police station empties and after
the first car gets there and verifies
he's not a real cop it takes 20 minutes
for even a couple of cops to get back to
the station and stumble on the heist so
they were called in the morning about
the drugs getting stolen they went to go
talk to Michael Imperioli and now it's
been afternoon already
oh I tread man I guess the court will
neglect the search warrant issue because
of the iTrip clause in the law that's
gay white folks you got to sound like
them we were wondering if we can borrow
some brown sugar honey that still sounds
like a black guy trying to do a white
voice to me two counts are just found a
dead body and haven't even called it in
yet start poking around on all the
evidence with bare hands and this I'm
gone now that I've contaminated half the
crime scene Mike Lowrey continues
desecrating any and all actual evidence
at this murder scene I'm the first guy
through the door and I'm always the last
guy to leave the crime scenes this
comment would play a lot better if you
hadn't literally just bailed on a crime
scene to let homicide handle it bad boys
bad boys what you gonna do here's the
rarest of movie phenomena a roll credits
combined with a product placement it'll
be a quick $2,000 I've got plans with
Julie she's your roommate right yeah so
bring her sure bring your non-working
Girl best friend on a date with your
John that sounds like a normal thing to
do an out-of-work photographer doesn't
know how to cook but I am an excellent
provider of clunky exposition hmm we're
out of here what kind of prostituting do
you do that will enable this statement
to be true I should have told you sooner
about Eddie's private party question is
why did Eddie tell you about the private
party at all you look like a model in
that dress were you modeled for me max
because when I kill people I need to do
it in a theatrical way that makes no
sense
thank God the bathroom in the Capone
suite was upstairs and practically a
secret hideout so that this chick could
witness all the crime and allow the rest
of the movie to happen how does this in
any way muffle a gunshot now it doesn't
even matter if the gun is muffled he's
just shooting away without concern
because once you kill the hot girl
witnesses can't hear gunshots anymore
hey somebody's up there so let's alert
her to the fact that I know that and
give her a huge head start fun fact it
was clearly daytime five minutes ago and
they haven't been here that long and
here we are it's night all the sudden
yeah yeah convenient pool do you know
what the chances of surviving this jump
are I think I'd rather take my chances
with bad guy aim than do this looks like
we got two shades of lipstick over here
gentlemen
tons of detectives in this place and it
took narco Mike to come in here and find
a clue a five-year-old would have been
able to locate no guns this time they
needed a huge sledgehammer for this job
oh hey I don't give a damn about his
personal files the man's dead unblock it
that guy who was important in a drug
case apparently can have blocked files
when the head detectives were looking
for information
that no screw you but no I'm not talking
to nope it's a term you use baby screw
you as a captain rather than simply
telling his wife that he was talking to
some asshole on another phone Marcus
decides to explain what screw you means
and it sets up this hilarious
misunderstanding
oh well didn't bring a gun so I can't
kill him throwing him out the window is
enough my best friend and I'll only talk
to Mike Lowrey what a bunch of bullshit
also if not for the dead roommates
seemingly innocuous comment about only
trusting Mike Lowrey this murder witness
might actually trust regular cops or
even cops that work directly with Mike
Lowrey instead this movie has some
hilarious identity swapping in store
that you're just going to die for so
it's all worth it is my Larry
he doesn't talk that way meanwhile Julie
is on the other end of the line not
saying a damn thing I guess waiting for
this argument she apparently can't hear
before she says anything he misses a
prime chance right here to say okay yes
I'm not Mike Lowrey but I am the only
person around the ones to help you stay
alive and take you to Mike Lowrey
instead movie continues down terrible
mistaken identity rabbit hole he's twice
failed Mike Lowrey test yet this girl
still goes on to trust him you got a bag
dog of course this apartment has a back
door because they need a back door okay
so they found the Madam's house because
max had an address book that apparently
had her illegal place of employment
written down whatever are we now to
believe that the whore house has
addresses of all their call girls lying
around or was Max's address in her
address book and the bad guys are only
now showing up at this place wherever
the fuck anybody is all I see are shapes
and a bunch of who cares well this isn't
the car won't start cliche but it is a
card a second to screw the hero at the
moment he or she needs it most
yeah okay I understand we can see the
license plate it's up close and
beautifully lit that's the magic of
movies seeing license plates like this
however this guy is not seeing the
license plate like this he's too far and
it's too dark one of the guys who shot
max what guys all I saw were bullets um
you didn't see the bullets no way I told
you I am NOT going into protective
custody
no cops continue to allow witness to
dictate how cops cock important witness
sarkis tells the doorman that there's an
important witness in Mike's apartment
when that is precisely what you don't do
and he didn't need to do you mind
telling me where the hell you been the
last 12 hours what you didn't know
Mike clearly called for backup when he
went into the Madam's house which means
the police sirens we heard after he got
smashed through the window was his
backup which means the story of his
partner lying out the
should have gotten back to him pretty
quickly also after getting thrown
through a window and probably staying
overnight at a hospital Mike gets taken
directly to the police station instead
of his house where he would find out an
important witnesses stand either sleep
on my couch I wake up this morning I got
a Power Ranger stuck up my ass you are
raising some up kids then you don't know
what I've been through this whole scene
is brought to you by people not telling
people anything let's run it back
Marcus his wife kicked him out of the
house because he stupidly talked on two
phones at once and was unable to clear
up an easy misunderstanding meanwhile
Mike gets thrown through a window and
nobody tells Marcus about it the whole
night this makes it so Marcus doesn't
know what happened to Mike and now we
have a comedy scene I told you to secure
a witness not to shoot up a neighborhood
not once does Marcus ever say I found
the witness and then the bad guys came
in and started shooting up the place
what choice did I have
nope not once but Hey angry police
captain scene is angry wait wait a
minute what what the hell is going on in
here Mike finally asks the question and
no the concussion doesn't matter it sure
isn't gonna matter to the movie in a few
minutes anyway you left it by herself
our only give witness yeah I know pretty
damn stupid and II told the doorman
about her too but I don't understand why
you don't know this already everybody
wants to be like Mike yeah and you're
gonna be retired like him too oh that
must have been embarrassing with Michael
Jordan returned to the Bulls on March
18th 1995 and this movie came out a mere
20 days later there's too much moisture
down here this is why you don't set up
drug labs on docked sea vessels as usual
Michael Bay doesn't give it to how you
see the product just that you see it
there Air Jordans kids not being worn on
a table hey Michael who's the guy in all
the photographs mike has tons of
incriminating photos of himself all over
the house because of course he does I
thought that you know I thought it maybe
you're gay sure but wouldn't there be a
picture of book Marcus and Mike on this
thing this whole scene is set up so that
Marcus can deny he's gay and man is that
hilarious
so he steps to the door hmm my Mike
describes a story that is already better
than this movie you got it easy compared
to me living in ED that Zoo you call
home
the last time we saw Mike he was
regaling the kids with a story about a
drug bust and I'm having the best time
of his life and somehow that translates
into a bad experience if he had one we
didn't see it but I guess that time
needed to be filled with Hal Bologna has
made and dogs ding on carpets why would
Mike need to call Marcus's wife during
work hours at the office away from the
witness Marcus would make this call this
is fucking stupid I don't wait up don't
wait
phone plays a dial tone after someone
hangs up cliche this Eddie Dominguez
file cannot be that hard to get into why
is it my cast its captain to unlock the
file or any higher-ups how can you be
denied these important files during an
investigation
Jeff hey Larry chef hey Larry okay allow
me to this asshole knows that Marcus is
not mr. Lowry remember this detective
Burnette so even if Chet was told to
call Marcus mr. Lowry he shouldn't be
the least bit confused
he knows the entire situation so this
again is comedy that comes from a place
that makes zero sense why you ever get
the sense this script started out as an
episode of Frasier then they added a
deadly serious drug heist to it and
didn't see why that was a problem does
Mike's buddy usually show up unannounced
while he's on duty didn't we hear her on
the answering machine a minute ago which
was a call Mike never returned because
it wasn't there not to mention that
doorman Chet isn't doing his job is he
does it sway you one way or another to
find out like I just did that teo leone
was in an episode of Frasier this very
same year that isn't masseuse she
massages Shh and did you think you were
gonna be able to get a rub-and-tug while
your star witness is in the apartment
again Mike is a character who is nothing
but clueless the whole time I can't
believe this dude always wanted to be a
cop she was naked
titties without a little bit nope not
even a little bit you three fed out
naked
this identity ruse is still happening
Club ballet screenplay by Rob are
literal important shipment of ether
comes during Club hell's busy ass
nightshift with tons of witnesses and
delivery complications not to mention
convenience for the plot how did either
of the two main characters in this movie
think this obvious gun stash was going
to go unnoticed by the cabin fever
witness no I remember you
seriously this movie it won't have the
sink count to show for it but this movie
is one of the worst stupid girl with
stupid revenge idea is really fucking
stupid
we're standing out front arguing like a
couple of schoolgirls what do you say we
put an end to all this bickering huh
screenwriter his own argument about
these characters ends up in the
screenplay
can you stay focus screenwriters
argument with the director ends up in
the screenplay also me is this how
things are done in the cop world there's
a major suspect from an unheard-of
Police Station heist in this club right
now only two cops come into this crowded
Club to arrest a guy with a terribly
violent rap sheet meanwhile said
Department will send entire police force
when one supposed cop gets shot movie
expect me to believe bad guy who is
probably drunk and who only saw this guy
once from a distance is able to spot
Marcus in this crowded ass Club I know
this place is called club hell but I
still don't think it's wise or up to
fire code standards to have this many
fucking unattended candles in the
bathroom cop fails a proper copic also
bad guys fail at proper bad guy their
idea was to put a plastic bag over his
head
why didn't biker dude have a knife of
his own ain't there the view into the
men's restroom through the fish tank at
the bar I mean man this dude has fucking
cat eyes how the hell is he soaking
observant oh this is screwed up how do
you know that by simply looking at this
car in the dark during a high-speed
chase what am i smelling either
extremely flavor
again tonight of all nights how many
days per month on average is there even
a need for an ether delivery truck this
is protective custody
oh well lady first of all you refuse
protective custody and demanded to stay
at Larry's apartment second of all
you've then left that sanctuary to go to
the club on the killing spree so you are
in no position to bitch to anyone right
now about anything weird much like speed
they're going to drive on a road that
eventually runs out also much like speed
the same composer is basically playing
the same theme music in this movie this
movie should have been called the star
of The Fresh Prince of bel-air and the
star of Martin yell at each other
constantly in waste everyone's time it
goes all nearly did it dawn how is club
hell not still a viable lead considering
all that went down you were there for
five damn minutes
this action news helicopter captures
three people involved in a big explosion
on a closed Road and somehow they'll
either walk or drive back down this road
where this happened right behind them
retrieve Marcus's car from the club and
get all the way to the sky station
without anybody noticing that there's
nothing absolutely nothing more
important to mike than doing this guy
that killed max this identity switch
farce is still going on i thought he was
supposed to be smooth on and she's still
falling for it too
sure why not this movie should waste
more time with this nervous store clerk
because it's just a movie am i right
lazy anti critics uh-huh hilarious out
of context dialog but honestly if that
was really happening who would answer
the phone if marcus waits five seconds
this gets cleared up easily but honestly
why does it even need to be cleared up I
don't think this is like oh it's not
it's also stupid as hell considering the
bad guys are potentially watching this
house or this car but whatever plot must
go on against now at a total dead end in
the story with the witness kill the bad
guy is assigned tonight is the night to
go to Marcus's house and stake it out
which just happens to be the night that
he thinks mike is banging his wife so
when he shows up a series of events
leads to more bad guys getting caught
and the plot can happen again yeah it's
broken neck right there here's Marcus
again leaving his witness vulnerable to
attack and unable to flee so this is a
stakeout I imagine why every cop show
and movie for 40 years has accurately
depicted the monotony of stakeouts where
did you get any other impression
there is there he is you guys were
waiting for him to show back up last
night you're still awake
eating Twizzlers so when did you miss
his car coming home hey this is real cop
stuff okay this is not Charlie's Angels
that's racist she can't hurt her to take
a peek how is this guy a cop worse cop
sever continued to be horrible will
somehow win in the end
that guy just happens to be monitoring
for spies and sponsor our heroes and
despite the fact that Mike saw him
looking straight at the hiding place
holding his own binoculars he still let
Julie have the binoculars and risk
everything standing on a trestle near
the River Drive in 34th streets
intersection was captured two nights ago
by our six Action News team but was it
newsworthy for two whole days until just
now this Marcus yells at the helicopter
scene didn't happen in fact this so
didn't happen it's like studying every
frame of the Zapruder film for 35 years
and then one day you happen to see Lee
Harvey Oswald whitewater rafting through
Dealey Plaza while holding an iPhone
bullets guns handcuffs and the key to
handcuffs continue to sit in an
unlockable cabinet like clean dishes at
your house she's so mad she left her to
elementary school boys and home alone to
come bitch out Marcos yes I'm here to
kill my husband Marcos Burnett and that
I'd be the tall one or the short one
dumbest person ever hilarious scene
marital discord which is entirely
avoidable if Marcos just says the
witness thought I was Mike and the boss
made me continue being Mike right now or
just tells his wife the truth in the
beginning Jesus if his wife can't find
us I'm a lot better off on my own you
already knew that you were staying at
Mike Lammers apartment a place that his
partner's wife would definitely know but
baby she's a material witness talk about
burying the lede this scene has fine
people shooting guns and no one hits
anything they aim at the entire time
someone dives someone shooting at this
place someone is here that guy this
flips mold things distractions this
victim kidnapping brought to you solely
because of the stretch then identity
swamp bullsh reveal coming when it did
and by the way where is her goddamn
veggie burger okay so in order to get
rid of the one witness to the hookers
murder you go shoot up an apartment
lobby that has security cameras in it
and kidnap said witness on camera how
does this help you legally speaking is
he really going to catch up to the car
by running hell they could have outrun
Mike just by obeying the traffic laws
but for some reason they really needed
to get out of there and wreck every car
in existence why haven't they killed her
yet what are they waiting for they're
willing to kidnap her in broad daylight
with witnesses and a film record of the
event but are waiting to kill her for
some reason
though thankfully this Miami chase takes
place in Atlanta traffic
the bad guys keep hitting cars stuck in
traffic to give Will Smith time to keep
up Michel de Dutch angles the shit out
of this running shop this of course
after giving us all that Dutch up and
for the whole movie what the fuck just
happened
Mike was outside rounding the corner and
then this asshole outside shows up and
shoots at him inside the movie just
flipped dimensions and logic and they
made a noble dude not even in the chase
suddenly appear I am certain that this
dude's existence is merely a hypothesis
that doesn't have enough empirical
evidence to become a theory these
basketball gods came in riding machines
to literally become the day uses ex
machina z' the chase needed shooting the
tires out would have been easier and
safer ah movies where no one inside the
car whoever shoots through the roof at
the guy on top of the car actually aims
at the center of the roof fresh prints
ex machina slow-motion regret I'm
keeping your sweet little friend for
four hours until I make my deal for no
reason I just put a bullet in the
chemist if put my time table also all
that either that got blown up didn't
help either but I blame the chemist more
than the driver are you guys for that
the other one is for the colonel wait
that bad guy called just to taunt the
cops I finally got the authority to shut
you down as of today you're all
reassigned somehow you weren't fired yep
you nearly have to be Inspector Gadget
incompetent to get fired off the Miami
police force also thank God the
unnecessary internal affairs subplot
finally pays off a prisoner is openly
hacking a computer inside of a police
department for guys who just got
reassigned on a case okay so they
couldn't access the file because she had
something to hide
but I'm still trying to figure out why
they didn't get somebody to legally do
this in the first place
surely a judge or somebody higher up
could have opened this thing a long time
ago without her help this is one of the
most important parts of their case and
they sat and argued about bullshit for
nearly an hour and a half instead of
pursuing it all so why isn't she dead
that no qualms about killing the guy who
helped them with the ventilation plans
it's 60 years you know that is that why
you kept her alive to tell her that I
still don't understand how her being
alive right now helps you in any way you
assholes might actually be even stupider
than she is this is real
got some for you let's go ah let that be
a listen to you even racist rivals can
find a way to work together when a white
girl's life is in the balance
I need a SWAT team helicopters we're
calling all cars here baby only I don't
know where I need them then didn't you
call a bit too soon then does it make
any sense to have them drive and fly in
any direction until you know where you
need them no one I bet yourself in the
all hangar section what incredibly
insightful correct assumption where they
got an itch
I'd love to scratch it all bad guys are
rapists or at least pretty damn close
sure they keep barrels of ether here at
the airport where the bad guys decided
to make the deal why not even though the
ether is supposed to be in the lab where
they cut the dough they keep stores of
it here for pretty much no reason I can
think of here's where Michael may honed
his particular brand of obscenely
incomprehensible action sequences yes
dive behind the propane tank you smart
good the one guy they don't give a gun
is the one guy who could've killed Mike
you forgot your boarding pass rejected
lines included keep your tray tables in
the upright position and your seat
cushions can be used as a floatation
device and always bet on black with the
sheer amount of electricity explosions
fire bullets and other hazardous
materials around this place everyone who
even looks at it should be dead I'm
calling bullshit on him catching up to
this car by running and jumping oh and
Michael Bay was born entire movie comes
down to dick-measuring drag race they're
this close to the wall but it now takes
10 seconds of spinning before the bad
guys car hits the wall this guy is dead
I don't care what he does right before
my eyes what it says in the screenplay
this guy is dead you cannot survive that
wreck you definitely aren't walking or
possessing a torso and worth killing man
you guys just played chicken within
driving 200 miles an hour toward a
concrete wall and he lived which means
this guy is the most worth killing son
of a bitch I have ever seen he is
clearly a zombie and it's against God
not to kill it bad guy gives good guy a
morally justified reason to kill and
cleeshay also these horrible cops
continue to be horrible and didn't make
sure to handcuff this guy or search for
more weapons
as of today you're already signed
everything on this planet has evolved to
kill humans all the mics in the house
the champ is here the champ is here
I made a series of very bad decisions
and I cannot make another one why did
you make these decisions good good of my
family
you want badges mother flesh Badgers
Badgers we don't need no stinking
Badgers all I know is his name give me
his name
Keyser sze I'm just an errand boy
something closely looks to collect a
bill that's Rick I thought I thought I
am better yeah he wants a drink now okay
I'll bring it you must always work
sometimes 60% of the time it works every
time hey everybody if you have an
interest in a book about disabled
superhero kids I just happen to write
something like that and you can now
pre-order the eBook version the
audiobook is coming soon as well